vous n'y couperez page sur les amours
ont offert une interview funérailles
nationales
[Musique]
c'était un petit peu difficile pour vous
puisque vous êtes mort donc dit mort
comment alors bah je suis mort de
vieillesse
ouais vous l'avez trouvé comment le
discours de chirac à l'enterrement au un
peu tremblotante
et quand l'équipe de la star academy a
chanté emmenez moi ça vous a ému
oui surtout que c'était la nouvelle
équipe les anciens n'étaient pas venus
j'avais des béquilles vous aimeriez
qu'on dise pas de vous maintenant vous
êtes mort charles aznavour pas qu'on
dise du bien
ouais ouais mais du bien bien pour
n'importe quoi comme le grandissime vous
grandit tous avec vos ventes de disques
sont repartis c'est énorme depuis que
vous êtes mort à vous avez revu mes
arrières petits-enfants et elle
s'enfonça est ce qu'il ya des oeuvres
posthumes des trucs que vous avez jamais
publiées et en vivant et qui vont
ressortir maintenant comme les beatles
ah oui oui j'ai laissé ma voix sur des
badges électroniques nouvelle et ils
ajouteront lors qu'est ce qu'ils
voudront ajouter de sucre sociale est ce
que vous savez qu'on va rebaptiser rue
aznavour la rue sarah that
ah oui oui ça c'est de la noël qui est
toujours maire de paris qui était sarah
that je sais pas un violoniste espagnol
alain grand violoniste espagne je me
suis renseigné quand ils se diraient pas
simplement fikiel nom est dire si ses
envies pour le reste non je me suis
renseigné
c'était quoi me dernier mot avant de
mourir charles aznavour je reviendrai
bravo
[Musique]